BIG TECH CULTURE:
It’s no secret that big tech companies pay
out compensation figures that aren’t comparable
to any other industry. Engineers fresh out of
college are able to earn nearly $200,000. With
just a couple of years of experience, they can
up that to $300 to $400,000. And by the time their
in their 30s, they’re often earning $500,000 to $1
million per year. These jobs also often come with
a bunch of perks like unlimited paid time off,
the ability to work from anywhere in the world,
free food, stock in the fastest growing companies,
and so on. If you ask the average person, the only
real downside of working at big tech is that there
may be some level of moral compromise. I mean,
at this point, it’s really no secret how a lot
of these companies make money. Even when it’s not
straight up data collection and privacy intrusion,
it’s often monopolization, anti consumer policies,
and abusing of power. But, this moral dilemma is
only the tip of the iceberg, and is often
the least of your concerns when it comes to
surviving and advancing at big tech. The reality
is that despite their inviting looking offices and
seemingly employee friendly policies, working at
big tech is much more like being a professional
athlete. If you follow sports, you’ll often hear
about contracts that are worth tens of millions if
not hundreds of millions of dolalrs. But, actually
cashing in on the full value of these contracts is
easier said than done. Usually, up half or more of
these contracts are paid out based on performance,
and unless you’re able to keep up world
class performance for 5 or 10 years straight,
you’re only can walk away with a fraction of the
top line value. It’s not that dissimilar at big
tech. You get paid sky high salaries, but you’re
also expected to perform at world class levels.
The moment that you don’t, you’re cut from the
team. And this isn’t speculation or anecdotal
either. You can go onto to Netflix’s official
company culture page and you’ll see them say
quote “We model ourselves on being a professional
sports team, not a family. A dream team is about
pushing yourself to be the best possible
teammate, caring intensely about your team,
and knowing that you may not be on the team
forever. Dream teams are about performance,
not seniority or tenure. It is up to the manager
to ensure that every player is amazing at their
position, plays effectively with others and
is given new opportunities to develop. That’s
how we keep winning the championship.” So,
here’s the truth about working at big tech.
THE PRESSURE COOKER:
Out of all the big tech companies,
the company with the most cutthroat environment
is no doubt Netflix. And before we discuss the
innerworkings of Netflix, I wanted to clarify that
I’m not trying to paint any of these companies
in a bad light. Netflix, for example, is often
the most generous of any company in the entire
world when it comes to comp. You know those multi
six figure and 7 figure contracts that you hear
about at big tech companies. Well, most of them
are largely made up of stock comp and bonuses.
At Netflix, however, the entire comp is purely
cash. So, it’s no wonder why they expect so much,
and I’m not criticizing that by any means.
Rather, I want to show how working at these
companies is often not as rosy as you might
imagine and that there is definitely a price
to pay. With that being said, let’s jump into
the Netflix pressure cooker starting with their
policy of extreme openness and quote on quote
“radical transparency”. At most companies,
compensation and performance is something that is
discussed behind closed doors with just your boss
and maybe your boss’ boss. This is designed to
minimize conflicts between employees regarding
compensation and keep performance reviews private.
At Netflix, it’s the exact opposite. Everyone who
is director or above has access to the salaries
not just their direct reports but everyone at the
entire company. And as for performance reviews,
these are even more accessible. Everyone who
is an admin or up has access to the performance
reviews of everyone at the entire organization.
You’re probably thinking that this would lead
to a lot of awkward conversations. You know,
always knowing how your peers are perfomring and
how much their earning and that they know the
same about you, but that’s kind of the point.
Netflix hopes that by making this information
widely accessible, it encourages employees to
constantly improve to survive. For example,
if you know that you’re the worst performing
director while getting paid the most,
you know that it’s time to step the hell up unless
you wanna be cut next quarter. And believe me,
Netflix doesn’t think twice when it comes
to firing people, and no one is “safe” which
brings us into the keeper test. Netflix encourages
their management to constantly evaluate whether
they would rehire and/or fight for their
direct reports. If the answer is ever no,
it’s time to fire them. And don’t think that you
can be the chill manager that doesn’t do this
either. If you’re the chill manager, you’ll come
off as being soft and soon find yourself on the
chopping block because like I said, no one is safe
and this applies to even C level executives. If
you’ve been a Netflix subscriber for a while, you
probably remember how garbage their recommendation
algorithm was back in the mid 2010s. Some
of you would argue that it’s still garbage,
but it has gotten a lot better and that’s thanks
to the keeper test. In 2017, after receiving a
bunch of negative feedback about curation, Netflix
decided to fire their Chief Product Officer that
was responsible for the curation algorithm: Neil
Hunt. This was despite Neil being a personal
friend of Reed Hastings and an OG employee who had
been there since 1999. And that was a rather soft
sacrifice. In mid 2021, Netflix fired 3 marketing
executives at the same time for not conforming to
the company’s policy of radical transparancy.
For perspective, that was half of their entire
executive marketing team. As you can see,
Netflix doesn’t hold back, but atleast Netflix
is completely transparent about that. They’re
cutthroat and their proud about it. The same,
however, cannot be said about their big tech
peers who often use much more underhanded tactics.
GOOD COP BAD COP:
The king of underhanded tactics is none other
than Amazon who very much has a culture of churn
because that’s how boss Bezos likes it. In fact,
Bezos isn’t a big fan of tenured employees because
he thinks that people simply get more comfortable
and lazier with time leading to a march to
mediocrity. As such, Amazon has a bunch of
policies to constantly churn through employees
starting with PIPs or Performance Improvement
Plans. Every year, Amazon has a policy of firing
the bottom 10% of their workforce. This way, the
quality of the workforce is always theoretically
improving. In reality, this often just leads to
a bunch of toxicity, office politics, and bad
blood. In fact, it’s common practice for Amazon
managers to hire to fire which is exactly what
it sounds like. If you’re an Amazon manager with
a solid team, it’s common to hire someone just
so that you can fire them at the end of the year
and preserve your core team. This also works
perfectly with Amazon’s compensation structure
which only pays out the majority of the stock
comp in the 3rd and 4th years. So, they’re able
to get away with paying much less to employees
who get churned out. But, coming from Amazon,
I don’t think any of that is really surprising.
What may be surprising, however, is the various
tactics that Google and Facebook employ. Unlike
Amazon or Netflix, Google and Facebook are much
more sly in their approach as they like come of
as the good guy. As such, they tend to employ good
cop strategies. For example, the main reason that
Google serves free breakfast, lunch, and dinner is
not because they love feeding everyone great food
but to maximize on productivity. If great food is
served on campus, it’s less likely that people
will go out for lunch. In fact, it’s likely that
a lot would simply work through lunch or atleast
spend a lot less time at lunch. Also, the timing
of free food is positioned to increase the length
of the work day. For example, Google doesn’t start
serving dinner till 6:30 to 8 pm. As such, if
you come into work at 8 am and wanna partake
in free dinner, you can easily find yourself at
work from 8 am to 8 pm. It’s the same reason why
Google offers or atleast used to offer perks like
free massages, haircuts, and ping pong tables. All
of these perks are designed to keep you at the
office for as long as possible, and hopefully
work for as long as possible. Even more employee
friendly policies like unlimited paid time off
have much darker realities. When a company
offers unlimited paid time off, employees
feel a lot more guilty when taking days off. In
fact, the average employee with unlimited PTO only
takes 11 days off per year, while the average
employee with limited PTO takes of 17 days,
and that’s just what you see at first glance. It
turns out that 42% of employees with unlimited
PTO actually end up working even during their
vacation days, and it gets even worse. When you
have limited PTO and you don’t use all of it, you
have the ability cash out this PTO for cash when
you leave even if it’s because you got fired.
With unlimited PTO though, there is no accrued
PTO meaning that there’s nothing to cash out
when you leave even though you barely took any
vacation. After all, they hire the most talented
and competitive people in the world, and they
dangle the opportunity to have even more power,
money, and influence in front of them. I think you
can guess what sort of environment this would lead
which brings us into truth about big tech culture.
EARNING YOUR WAGE:
As you can see, Netflix has the whole professional
athlete model, Amazon has the churn model, and
Google and Facebook have the good cop model. But,
if this is the reality of working at big tech, why
do we never hear about this? Even more than that,
why do we always hear about these companies
being the places in the world to work? Well,
this has a lot to do with selection bias and a
great analogy for this is AP testing. If you’re
not familiar with AP tests, it’s what a lot
of American high school students take to earn
college credit. The lowest score on the test is
a 1 and the highest score is a 5. One of the AP
subjects with the lowest 5 rates is Physics 1 with
only 8% of students getting a 5. 27% of students
actually get the lowest score, a 1. This isn’t
surprising given that Physics is an extremely
tough subject. You know what is surprising though?
One of the AP subjects with the highest 5 rates is
Physics C E&M, a much harder and advanced physics
class. 31% of test takers get a 5 on Physics C E&M
and only 12% get a 1. A subject with even better 5
rates is Calculus BC where a whopping 42% of test
takers get a 5 and only 6% get a 1. Does this mean
that Physics C and Calculus BC are way easier than
Physics 1? Of course not. It’s just that only
super smart people take these advanced classes
in the first place and they end up doing really
well. It’s the same thing with these big tech
companies. It’s not that these jobs are actually
super chill and pay super well. They’re actually
hypercompetitive and extremely keen on ensuring
that you earn your salary. But, only extremely
talented hyper competitive individuals who thrive
in this sort of environment are actually hired to
begin with. As such, big tech is actually much
more comparable to other high pressure fields
like investment banking and hedge funds as opposed
to normal companies who happen to hire software
engineers. And this is the truth that is often
lost when discussing careers at big tech. Like
with any industry, the payout is proportional to
the expectations. With something like finance,
the high expectations are immediately
evident. You have to outperform the market,
something that 90% of hedge fund managers fail
to do. With tech, the high expectations aren’t
as evident from the outside, but believe
me, there is no free lunch at big tech,
both literally and figuratively. And that is
the true price of working at big tech. Atleast,
these companies pay massive salaries to
compensate for that. Oh wait, nevermind,
they’re making moves to dramatically decrease
pay. Check out this video to learn more.